martin biron christian dufour pas
journée bonsoir sur le sondage c'est pas
dans quelle mesure ça vous étonne
ou pas on va regarder ensemble
rapidement le fait que bon les deux
tiers des canadiens 64% veulent se faire
vacciner
pas demain matin mais presque ce petit
tour de table à ce sujet c'est beau
c'est ici on s'attendait à saint martin
je pense que les gens veulent pas servir
de cobaye puis ils veulent avoir toutes
les informations nécessaires leur disant
dans quoi à quoi ils s'exposent savoir
quels types d'effets secondaires
ils vont ils vont subir pour l'instant
de quand même assez peu d'informations
et même les scientifiques ont peu
d'informations il manque de données ils
disent qu'ils ont accès seulement
communiqué de presse alors oui on veut
avoir un peu plus de détails sur un vain
d'attendre le bol et cesser ses dents
mal je pense itunes sagesse
quant à christian bassez c'est rassurant
parce qu'on pouvait craindre que ce soit
plus bas on vit en fait dans une culture
sanitaire où le risque zéro s'est imposé
donc c'est un peu compréhensible que
pour beaucoup de gens avant de
s'embarquer ils veulent en fait savoir
les conséquences choisi personnellement
dans comptes ifec on vit quand même
cataclysme planétaire
une très jolie tragédie historique créé
énormément de dommage à tous les niveaux
je suis toujours étonné de voir que des
gens qui sont pas capables d'assumer le
risque qui va avec un vaccin qui est
quand même
l'issue la vidéo kitsch mais en tout cas
c'est rassurant ça va peut-être plus
bobst a en france
paul oui surtout que le risque de ne pas
se faire vacciner on le fait porter aux
autres dont un post faire vacciner c'est
un geste individualiste voire égoïste
moi je note que les scientifiques disent
qu'il faut un taux minimal de près
soixante dix pour cent de vaccination
pour atteindre le résultat espéré
on est presque déjà eu à vendre de
savoir quel vaccin serait administré
puis avant d'avoir tous les détails sur
ce ou ces vaccins donc c'est quand même
assez positif le plan sondages et
l'autre donnée puis
on vient d'en parler un peu
indirectement mais 71 pour sa déjà se
disent d'accord avec la phrase je
m'inquiète des effets secondaire aux
risques associés on va le voir à l'écran
au vaccin 71% qui s'inquiètent c'est
normal compte tenu qu'il a fallu ingéré
ce de manière extrêmement rapide martin
ouais mais c'est ça et les le mot
présume que les tests ont été faits au
complet mais mes hits comme je disais il
manque pas mal d'informations mais à
partir du moment où on explique bien ce
que va faire le vaccin parce qu'il est
petit et on les scientifiques disent
qu'on n'est même pas certain qu'on va
être que qu'on ne pourra pas de
transmettre le virus une fois vacciner
et on va être protégés des symptômes
mais on risque de rester contagieux
alors il ya des zones d'ombré qui fait
et qui font qu'on ne peut être pas on
veut enlever vous verrez veut de
certaines réponses mais si on regarde
les vaccins qui existe présentement est
quand même des maladies importantes qui
ont été presque éradiquer la rougeole la
polio la bâtisse elle alors qu'un
bienfait des vaccins est là il a connu
deux quand même tué des milliers des
milliers de personnes mais maintenant
est-ce qu'on va être plus malade en se
faisant vacciner pour l'instant on n'a
pas toutes ses réponses la wii christian
barou grande bretagne où la campagne de
vaccination commence de la santé
publique que la botte vivre avant que je
prends beaucoup de vis moi tout respect
pour marseille moi je trouve pas ça
normal à ce point là qu'on se préoccupe
à ce point et lot d'effets secondaires
possibles si on n'est pas dans le risque
zéro le la vigueur il ya un risque que
la seule chose qui est sûre c'est qu'on
va tous mourir en un jour qu'on attache
à ce point-là de l'importance à des
effets secondaires quand même si
statistiquement sont pas si différents
ça nous empêche de le faire vacciner
planque 11 jours avant c'est là la vraie
question c'est est de vous plus inquiet
du risque de lier à un vaccin ou à une
pause être vaccinés ici on pose la
question comme ça je pense que attraper
la coved c'est pas mal plus inquiétant
que de possibles effets secondaires et
genres et mais je réponde à 164% dix
mois je vais y aller alors même si j'ai
des craintes je vais y aller alors c'est
les pieds qui qui votent un autre
tableau le de 72,6 que je vous montre
est ce intéressant parce que les gens
vont quand même loin ils sont presque
ont rendu obligatoire pour voyager en
avion
un vaccin pour aller à l'école pour l
eau restant dans un bar et disent oui le
fameux passeport immunitaire on est prêt
à nous le faire imposer dans certains
domaines de la vie christian legrand la
possibilité légale de parce que je
comprends de rentrer deux factions
obligatoire mais je serai vraiment mieux
qu'on en arrive au lof
mais en même temps je pense que on peut
l'imposer de façon indirecte comme vous
l'aviez en fait c'est très
compréhensible que des compagnies
d'avion exige que les gens a été vacciné
avant de les accepter ou d'autres
insurgés après c'est comme ça que ça va
procéder il va le marché va faire son
travail
ça va se faire de façon indirecte et on
n'aura pas à aller jusqu'à la
vaccination obligatoire qui aurait
vraiment des effets pervers qui pourrait
vraiment nuire à l'objectif on a parlé
la semaine dernière un christian g t-il
entre autres et on disait quand les gens
vont voir les premières images à la
télévision de gens se faire vacciner
le l'impatience va augmenter il envoie
vos grains pays si l'on faisait bon mais
à quand notre tour
je vous propose un extrait de la cin de
de tahoua aujourd'hui le chef
conservateur qui revient à la charge
avec ça au canada notre gouvernement
libéral dit seulement quelques canadiens
vont être vaccinés en septembre comment
les canadiens vont se sentir quand
l'économie américaine dréau mais nous on
doit rester en confinement
pourquoi secretary canada est
actuellement en train d'étudier à quatre
différents vaccins de façon accélérée et
on en est sécurisé des dizaines de
millions de doses de tous irak c'est
pour les canadiens bon elle ça tourne
comme ça depuis une semaine at à wallace
est constamment la même critique paul
l'opposition disent rien dû faire ceci
cela le drama qui répond regarder on a
commandé
on attend on tourne en rond un peu et
puis on sait pas ce qu'est le canada a
perdu sa capacité de production
c'est pour la photo gouvernement trudeau
ça résulte de décisions qui ont été
prises dans les dernières décennies mais
moi j'ai l'impression que ça c'est un
frein avant débat qui sera rapidement
oublié parce que le grand test pour le
gouvernement trudeau
c'est patent l'arrivée du premier vaccin
mais plutôt comment la campagne de
vaccination va être orchestrée sur le
terrain par le gouvernement trudeau et
surtout par les provinces parce que on
sait ça pose de formidables défis
logistiques pour entre autres la
réfrigération bon c'est pas ça très
actif
quel vaccin fille dans quelles
conditions il va devoir être transporté
garder ecce terra
mais pour scier ressources humaines les
gens qui m'ont bassinette chez terrain
ça ça va être très compliqué et j'ai
l'impression que ça et c'est surtout ça
le grand défi qui attend les
gouvernements et si le vaccin arrivera
en retard ça leur donne des arguments de
moins
pour essayer de se justifier s'il ya des
ratés parce qu'ils ont vraiment en ce
moment les administrations de se
préparer et germaine tolérance pour les
erreurs ou à parler très bientôt
moi je tousse le problème politique
majeur pour le gouvernement trudeau et
l'opposition conservatrice se sentit la
vulnérabilité et canadien aujourd'hui
nous au même temps qu'est ce qu'on fait
moi j'ai dit ah ça ne passait que je me
sentais un petit peu comme un citoyen de
seconde zone que je le pense encore le
canada pour moi c'était parce que
gouverner c'est prévoir
bon c'est vrai qu'on produit pas d'accès
mais j'ai lu aujourd'hui que des vaccins
qui sont utilisés en grande bretagne
actuellement ils viennent pour une bonne
part de belgique
donc c'est une chose de proposions des
vaccins on aurait pu les commandes et
nous s'il ya quand même toute une
infrastructure bureaucratique de santé
publique n'a pas l'air d'avoir pensé au
fait que le vaccin devrait plutôt prévu
cette semaine des britanniques se font
vacciner même comme qu'elle faisait ça
me choque que nous on nous parle dans
l'âme et 2021 éventuellement va être
vaccinés de l'access une bonne chose il
semble pour l avoir au plus sacrant mais
je n'ai pas dansé dans cette échoppe
martin garder votre idée je vais vous je
vais vous chanter encore plus
christian parce que dr tam qu'on connaît
bien a dit avec parce qu'on prévaut au
canada 6 millions de doses d'ici la fin
mars
donc 3 millions de personnes je parle
juste du file 1 3 million de personnes
vaccinées elle s'apprend du lowe's et la
docteure tam a dit ça sera pas suffisant
bien sûr même pour aller au début de la
clis de jean prioritaire on écoute
[Musique]
bon alors et elle continué donc il faut
en faire plus pour pour capable de
respecter notre séquence de vaccination
martin je pense que moi tu la sortie de
crise pourrait être politiquement
beaucoup plus
taxant que la crise elle-même la crise
on le vécu et on sait que comme on a
souvent pris l'expression c'est un peu
comme construire un avion en vol mais la
sortie de crise l'on peut la planifier
on peut la voir venir c'est certain
qu'avec trois millions de doses d'ici
mars on va se comparer au royaume uni et
adopte le royaume uni pense avoir
vacciner sa population d'ici pâques mars
là si on a seulement trois millions de
personnes au canada vacciner au québec
ça veut dire autour de 500 mille
personnes 700 mille personnes c'est 23%
en fait d'aider des trois millions de
doses dont ces prorata de la population
il y à un million et demi de personnes
qui ont plus de 65 ans au québec
alors c'est sans meadows là on n'a pas
vacciner tout le monde n'a pas vacciner
tous les travailleurs de la santé oms
n'a pas vacciner toutes les personnes
âgées
alors c'est pas tant que ça de doses
alors la docteure tendit une réalité
alors comment est ce que les choses vont
s'organiser pour la suite des choses
pour les gouvernements c'est important
de réussir cette sortie de crise très
bien où on a eu aujourd'hui on a une
vision à québec lé de la crainte qu'ont
à martin avec la vice première ministre
qui a dit bon mais les attroupements là
on va on veut y voir parce qu'avec les
cas qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est un
nombre de core core d'ailleurs depuis le
début les hospitalisations n'a pas assez
le 7 le cap des 700 allègrement on
écoute madame guilbeault qui nous parle
des efforts que les commerces commerçant
doit faire il y aura des règles dès
vendredi
il ya plusieurs commerces qui sont
fermées en ce moment entre août les
restaurants les bars et tous à eux ont
la chance d'être encore ouvert donc
c'est un peu le compromis qu'on leur
demande ce matin vous voulez rester
ouverts on veut vous restiez ouvert
qu'on vous demande de faire part de plus
pour que tout le monde puisse être
certain qu on n'augmente pas la
contagion dans ces lieux là
bien martin donc noël bon là ça c'est
pour le magasinage noël s'éloigne je
pense que wayne noël s'éloigne de plus
en plus écouter ça fait quand même bout
de temps je pense que le premier
ministre prépare les consciences en
disant écoutez c'est le 19 novembre ans
qu'il a annoncé la première fois les
quatre jours pour noël on est à mille
trois cent corps rappelez vous il y
avait dix faut se rendre en bonne mine
on n'est pas en bonne mille on est à
1500 alors l'addition va se rendre la
semaine prochaine
mais tous les indices nous disent que
peut-être qu'on en aura peut-être pas
d'eux peut-être un mais que si on
s'envoie vraiment vers l eau est très
prudent puis bon en fait il annonce
d'aujourd'hui je voudrais aller elle
remarquer qu'elle n'a pas été fait avec
la sécurité publique le docteur horacio
arruda était pas là ni son adjoint on
envoyait la vice première ministre et
expliquer ces données-là qui était pas
vraiment basée sur des éléments
extrêmement solide de la question était
posée il ya pas d y a pas d'éclosion
elègbè vous avez vu les images sur les
médias sociaux
alors on agit cela dit et je pense que
les mesures d'aujourd'hui visait une
minorité je pense que la majorité paie
pour les écarts de conduite d'une
minorité mais en mettant du mur à mur
comme ça dans tous les centres
commerciaux et tous les commerces en
place les choses et on peut sévir si
jamais m il faut faire peut-être pas les
christian apaisé aussi ceux qui sont
fermés puis qu'ils voient ce qu'ils sont
ouverts dans certains cas s'il presque
le bar ouvert la session
oui je pense que la plupart des
commerçants vont être contents en fait
sont presque soulagé la grande crainte
c'est d'être fermé là ils sont encadrés
donc ça les rassure ils disent ça
confirme qu'on va pouvoir rester ouverts
est ce une mesure qui est pas trop
exigeante
très simple à appliquer et de toute
façon il ya déjà plein de commerces
qu'ils l'appliquent moi je l' ai vécu
dans mon garage
il y avait une pancarte sur la porte on
ne sait pas plus de deux clients en même
temps puis c'est assez facile à
respecter donc je pense qu'il ya pas de
problème là
mais je te paye pour revenir sur ce que
martin a dit en effet tous les
indicateurs pour l'idée de fêter noël
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge
fallait que la situation s'améliore et l
empire
on pourrait à martin a parlé du nombre
de cas on pourrait ajouter aussi le
nombre d'hospitalisations aussi le taux
de reproduction du virus qui est à la
hausse
et le gros gros travail du gouvernement
qui a sa part de responsabilité dans le
contrat c'est le dépistage et le traçage
et s'est passé en pas encore tout à fait
à la hauteur donc ceux qui veulent fêter
noël
dre de se calmer l'optimisme est ce que
c'est mal parti
oui christian d'un bon moi je pas sûr
que c'est si facile d'application qu'ils
soient dans les grands centres
commerciaux
en fait il faut quand même pas oublier
que c'est l'hiver puisque il va voir des
files d'attentes dans c'est vrai qu'avec
le chiffre de 1500 hancock est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est comme un coup de
massue donc c'est plus celle de
critiquer mais beaucoup de gens en fait
qui notait que les villes y restera en
l'état puisqu'elle a été fermée alors
que parfois il y avait des gens dans les
centres d'achats qui faisait pas
beaucoup d'efforts donc le gouvernement
agit bas on n'a pas d'autre choix
mais jusqu'à quel point c'est
scientifiquement là c'est quelque chose
qui va vraiment aider à diminuer de pas
même j'en ai aucune idée on n'a pas
d'autre choix la nuit c'est sûr que ça
ne se peut pas nue et assène plus grande
distance entre les gens que moyennement
merci on va en reparler évidemment la
décision vous l'avez souligné la semaine
prochaine annoncé martin le 11 décembre
ou peut-être même avant par monsieur
legault merci beaucoup à vous trois